okay okay it is your boy psycho babble
back in action you just you just can
never be too sure that you're recording
Annie you know okay I'm recording okay
ask you this max for breath that's fine
I just dried today I figure chicken
nugget character go all the way honey
bear yeah it controls I thought it was
like okay okay I really don't know what
the hell's going on but you know let's
just do this okay
life's too short life is too short okay
hello sir okay let's see what this movie
is today I sucked dry I think I've seen
this already
can a okay
that [ __ ] it are they gonna [ __ ]
shot okay guys that's [ __ ] it now
that was short and sweet act for breath
okay
wait let's see what my directors notice
built a character turning-point step
back breathe
remember that's good okay and the Sun we
are one this whole way going black black
and white things crazy Tameka
we're so close I can feel it there can
be no doubt no hesitation that only will
unbreakable that is what we have that is
what we are in the end and I can you
said it best sister you said it best
okay best casting directors gotta be
some goodies in this moment
[ __ ] I'll [ __ ] place don't [ __ ]
place is getting dirty
um attention stowaways two of them okay
call but the love when a girl that being
on site so I have really been confused
by this whole thing I mean I thought I
was okay here's what I thought the
[ __ ] Saddam just was I thought it was
like I don't act they're just there's a
bat [ __ ] [ __ ] director and they threw
me on this and the place also happened
to be [ __ ] Holland it says weather
should going on but apparently we missed
on the fact that I me kid like I was a
stowaway and I'm reliving them in like a
PTSD ton of thing why they keep telling
twisting me right am i [ __ ] missing
something
[ __ ] missing something in it because
that's locked
so what's over here
there is the pedal it doesn't [ __ ] up
here
should we [ __ ] worried okay
what the [ __ ] never have I started level
so shittily boy girl okay anything in
here that I need the touch now I'm
looking I don't say [ __ ] shut and I'd
say [ __ ] shut okay again [ __ ] desi
I think it's this I got a touch right no
I got a pretty like a [ __ ] pot or
something here looks like I got a Coke
or some [ __ ] like that
okay is there like a pot I can crap any
pop I feel like you guys need me to get
a pot or something what's this pot doing
here alright what the [ __ ] now this is
open
okay
locked I'm losing my damn mind okay so
over here it's closed whoa that is
[ __ ] weird yeah no wonder no one are
so [ __ ] confused get the [ __ ] out of
my face holy [ __ ]
that one got me don't [ __ ] golly that
was a cheap shot
that's a [ __ ] cheap shot get out away
mice holy [ __ ] that would scared the
[ __ ] out of me just share the [ __ ] day
of my life holy [ __ ] dick on a
chicken [ __ ] deck of a chicken
oh [ __ ] was that I mean I look I don't I
literally don't have any [ __ ] idea no
land left
hello [ __ ] yes stupid [ __ ] wow I'm so
angry
you're just gets so [ __ ] shocked
you're angry
that is that another sonogram [ __ ] did
they like tell themselves or nothing
why - shake he's fallen from the [ __ ]
ceiling okay
whoa that is trippy as [ __ ]
okay
yes step add mice is that ah I don't get
[ __ ] here
I don't know where to go they got me hey
got back act for breath okay maybe I
could find out where I gotta go real
quick
[Music]
okay reminder water now I landed it's
all good it's all good people say don't
I don't even know what [ __ ] direction
up and down is
all right
okay
Oh
the [ __ ] lose the character find
yourself that [ __ ] married date oh no
oh yeah 3cp out with that [ __ ]
no find the character with yourself okay
it's like a [ __ ] whale cat [ __ ]
hate well cats
I mean your [ __ ] junkie that was a
[ __ ] cheap shot that was a [ __ ]
cheap shot okay we're going there we're
gonna [ __ ] run it work it
we're good we're [ __ ] run in it wait
dad it buys I did it
what really shows down here
the [ __ ] how do I get in there
okay though I want a white [ __ ] to wear
like the [ __ ] magic shoes to get in
there
what is this okay [ __ ] it it's [ __ ]
wet
shut that [ __ ] is disturbing that [ __ ]
oh hello little mouse a nice to see you
again yeah [ __ ] joke scrape your
[ __ ] that it's TOCOM [ __ ] is way to
come oh yeah I've been in this hotel
room before when it locks behind you and
that person demands more money than you
originally said you would pay them
same [ __ ] hallway
how's that [ __ ]
how many times I'm gonna [ __ ] through
this don't know why you stupid [ __ ]
now here where you go
[ __ ] hurts
yeah it's an underwater there
if I can just fly through that so I went
through the door it's the same [ __ ]
weird-ass [ __ ]
it does not like when I touch that
here we go we're going all the way honey
back
shall we [ __ ] that uh uh you know I
don't think I tell it like this games
I'll take scary for her
[Music]
now get out of here
[Music]
huh
the nets on computers now
natural
I turn that [ __ ] off [ __ ] fly
through here now [ __ ]
but it's the butt man
or fly it or foot what the [ __ ] because
you are dumb
okay what's in here okay it's had that
guy [ __ ] [ __ ] fly into this [ __ ] now
don't look fetch just [ __ ] now
just [ __ ] run fit now that out now
now I'll [ __ ] the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
we're almost there [ __ ] okay but it's
right dunk it your [ __ ] boots
wet that's Gary [ __ ] that's
disgusting
okay icon that rafter sure okay I guess
I ain't gonna that room
okay just sorry just passing through
they're [ __ ] serious bro
okay Shh s
as some disturbing [ __ ]
well oh wait that lead oh okay but sorry
didn't know one turn the Sun I guess
how do you guys like it
[ __ ] missing something alright
yeah
they don't seem too interested in it
okay there's something I can't do up
there
okay I gotta go in the light the [ __ ] is
that
oh [ __ ]
that's a [ __ ] depressing [ __ ]
not sure I need that no thank you
whoa what is that that's a flower right
now chef okay I guess I'll climb that
the mountain I have luxury yeah that's a
lot of what hair it smells a little bad
but that's okay I see it's there for
okay
I took it wait my supposed take all this
in it
[Music]
and lost the plot
now
and I will okay okay I get out of this
ride okay here we go that's just crazy
oh good i trippin hey what
[ __ ] that
how about batch okay
the [ __ ] am i moving pictures real quick
no it is it's a chaise saying huh
nothing with that I got out chase saying
I got some great great clicks
I was here ready go finally some [ __ ]
puzzles
[Music]
they said pasta holy [ __ ] this is the
scene for there would be seven you think
we're the [ __ ] opening scene it's so
cool okay
yes I was doing here looking for a
[ __ ] number
best gust thing I feel like I'm not
supposed to be back Jack in here like if
there's gotta be something here right
okay Oh backtrack a little bit
okay there's no backtracking this is a
one-way journey
it's a quiet [ __ ] wet
I don't know the [ __ ] suppose that
they're here
this is pretty
yeah
this is Gabbie grass
okay now I can't tell if it's chasing
after me this is a 1907
all right touch them they're gonna freak
out ready
okay
I can't remember if that was a thing for
seven I think it was
I think it was like the [ __ ] or
something you're all [ __ ] things in
the movie se7en say they find I had
something I'd like to write I got a
friend here yes
why does making that noise
back
ah
oh yeah they're gonna are oh it's not
worth it yet
this what's the hand okay and this one
let's go fat I know I thought my sty
right your fray 7 says yes a achievement
a then what's the [ __ ] combination
[Music]
yeah [ __ ] what I don't really know what
the [ __ ] I saw see doing how they did
anything in here though
hmm
how do I get back to my [ __ ] original
now
now
I can't try these ways
that turgor do nothing
okay there's only one more spot then and
it's the other front of the Eagle okay
let's see here
where's Diego see over here
yes I can still save oh there we go
that's silly rats yes step it batch
all right where are we [ __ ] going no
[ __ ] now
they say where to go
get the [ __ ] out [ __ ]
okay here we go
the way got it the way that gut boys way
did gut it's my room finally
what the [ __ ] that's a mouse game the
mouse is [ __ ] talking over say yes
stupid [ __ ] is this set head yeah just
it's someone movie se7en there's a head
in there
Jim where are you going Jim there we go
which way
this stupid bet stay here where you
going
now and I hear shut
where is this [ __ ] going ready go
that little [ __ ] [ __ ]
rabbi
all right wait a minute that is we made
it underwater now
can't tell for underwater they be are
underwater character it won't be me and
you see me yeah we're underwater dude
there's [ __ ] of barnacles on this [ __ ]
this is the nude we got this mr. mouth
okay what is that you are so getting out
which way you are so whichever way that
and as long as he that I can't stand
that one the new sound thing but I don't
want to go through 80 of them okay let's
sit at this guest thing I don't know
what this [ __ ] is but this is the fun
part let's hear it
oh [ __ ]
your [ __ ] jump scare sounds [ __ ]
I said
what is that oh it's a slipper just a
louse leper
let's see what our message of the day is
hello
play truth become break the second here
and now hello mm what the who the [ __ ]
am i him her him her huh
the part now is figuring out okay well
anyways um that was this episode it was
I was a good one
if y'all enjoyed I'll see you on the
next on ik